william roberts the fake rick ross yeah
what about that man why he a bad guy
tell me anything like a sweet guy what's
wrong with him they called me a rad I
took your car Mike and I drove it to the
thing and everybody recognized me and I
got a deal but I'm gonna keep the car
and I'm gonna get you nothing boy hey
everybody welcome to another episode of
hot box and I'm Evan Brittany and I'm
Mike Tyson Mike we got a great one we
have a sensation of legendary yes here
we have freeway Rick Ross welcome my
brother I'm good man
great to have you here man great to be
here you know I don't know man it's
crazy man Mike came up at the same time
like a run was almost nil
I knew people that knew Rick and stuff I
knew girls that normal stuff yeah yeah
we uh I think we went to New York and
watching fight like it's maybe it's 12
fight or something like wow really yeah
yeah that's when you know you boys
coming rookie that's crazy
we know my partner no man My partner was
like man this dude's gonna be the next
champ man come on as well let's go check
him out that's Pauly I'm going for next
champ let's go check them out let's go
check this out yeah yeah whoa it was
crazy
I mean good times yeah you've walked a
pretty unique and incredible path no
doubt no doubt it's it's been a journey
sort of mind-boggling listen but very
very my box yeah I mean people that you
were hassling with in the street man
they have normal job like you know me I
see a few hey man yeah
I mean with the jail you know did they
10 15 20 years and you know it was like
I can't do it again
you know I can't go that route so so
they squared up and got a job which is a
wise thing to do you know if you if you
can't beyond manure didn't you know get
a job but a job you know I just couldn't
work a job I gotta be entrepreneur I got
to be where I can go whenever I get
ready know when I get ready you know I
gotta be free I feel that man for people
who don't know your story where do you
start under a rock I know what it we're
going to the rock we dig the rock up and
be like hey you come out of it no you
know I started selling drugs as a 19
year old kid who who all of his dreams
had suddenly been taken away from him my
dream was to be a tennis player you know
was pretty good
you know did you meet at the Arthur Ashe
yeah my dad he came down to our high
school we had the best black tights to
avoid a Sherman we had the best high
school tennis team in the country really
yeah we did and ash came down and gave
us awards and we're not me cuz I wasn't
uh I was on JV at that time I wasn't on
the varsity team and Gail gave awards
and hit with the top three or four
players and it was amazing day man I was
like oh I know I'm in the rice would
yeah so uh I just I just took to it man
I fell in love with it
I didn't have anything else you know at
that time I couldn't read I couldn't
write basketball to football wasn't
gonna be the way because I was too
little you know and tennis was was
perfect for me so I jumped in and I
started putting my all into it and uh
too bad at the end of the rainbow when
it was time for me to graduate from high
school they found out I couldn't read a
ride and it was like
oh you're not going to college mmm your
dummy and I was kind of crushed by it
found myself back in South Central Los
Angeles in what in tendance we called no
man's land you know when you're in a
position on the court where you really
can't do anything and you don't know
what you're gonna do you know you're
just trying to survive and that's the
position I was in
so to go to prison and to get a life
sentence without the possibility parole
you know it's like right now you freaked
out right away did you say all of you
just calm down no just not that I knew
Mike when I was going to do the crime
that I was looking at a life sentence so
when I was going through the process it
was kind of kind of shocking but not not
totally cuz you know it's like you
deserve this
you know you earned this so it was kind
of shocking the hardest part was the day
that they actually gave it to me and my
mom was in court and and she broke down
you know my mom - Mike yeah yeah and
then they she had dinner with you and
every day she's like Oh Mike Tyson is so
nice you told her you totally she could
drive your car that's right yeah that
was one of her life oh my told me I
could drive her car he said miss pross
you can drive my car T once and you
leave knows my mom he didn't even know
your mom that's just how that's just how
he was carrying it so that was you know
one of the highlights of her life is
that man she can't his yelled and told
me yes yeah yeah she kind of Jillian
told me like man I was with Mike Tyson
in Cleveland he was including yeah yeah
she was with a Toro a boxer Oh boxer
named Toro from Cleveland and they
always at a restaurant and used like oh
yeah you can try that car
probably at lances so you know it's
crazy how I passed
our paths crossed in so many different
ways and you know now that we sitting
here we talking and your kids playing
your kid playing tennis my kids play
tennis you got the form I'm trying to
get a dispensary I mean this is so many
things in common and sports kind of get
that to you too you know where you have
that I got a win I don't want to lose I
want to be a winner and that's the
attitude that I have right now that come
from my upbringing you know we watched
our parents be losers and watch people
and I'm neighbor losers watch somebody
just lose everything we don't want to be
that way no watch the block talk about
the other people talk about your name
and your name is in the mud and [ __ ]
yeah and I think that that's mentality
is why so many young black men sell
drugs right now because they don't have
no other outlet but they don't want to
be a loser
you know like ain't taking welfare I
want food stamps and you know I can't
stand in line for the government cheese
I'd rather sell drugs and listen Rick
listen when I was in the streets right
late 1970s this is I guess couldn't sell
[ __ ] drugs on the coins can feel the
struggle be in the house away I had to
take it you know I mean I would take the
drug that kid enjoys couldn't be honest
excelling it to people's you know how to
patients no way how could you do it
you're amazing brother did you do it I
had to stay out all night I'll be like
my thing was kind of like the way you
work out though my you do a thousand
squats I read in the paper one time they
were saying Mike Tyson to a thousand
squats every day you know the animal
that's how my whole body [ __ ] up so
that's how I was about to run now I
can't even run do roadwork now my body
all [ __ ] up amen you know we put it
through the wringer I was taught that
the harder you train the more you would
achieve the hearty training will he
break down
if I had me breakdown yeah but my whole
body yeah yeah people Rick I really um I
watched your documentary last night
freeway
did you yeah ma'am cuz I wanted to just
brush see all the politicians talking
about understand it's just mind blowing
man well I want to ask you a question
just and I know that you do a lot of
speaking you get out there you know you
use the platform that you have to really
spread some positive good in the world
we have to I mean yeah I mean I mean we
all look at it when we're gone the one
thing that anybody want people to say
about him is that he was a good person
yeah you know like the deed that Mike
did with my mom well he don't even
remember yeah but she remembered yeah
you know and and and those are the
things that's gonna count you know when
you're no longer around when you can't
speak for yourself when other people
speak for you you want people to say
nice things about you you know like you
go and that's one reason I stopped going
to front rows because they go to frontal
and they send up there Nate lying about
this guy you know the guy was a piece of
[ __ ] guy helped nobody he took from
everybody he come in contact with and
and I don't want to be that person you
know I don't want to be the person that
people got to come in and make my family
feel good and tell a bunch of lies about
me you know I wanted to be where I
actually helped people you know where I
actually did good by other people and
I'm hoping that one day I can do more
good than I did bad when I saw cocaine
you know cuz I sold a lot of cocaine and
I saw a lot of people and I did that out
of ignorance because I didn't really
understand I didn't understand what
cocaine was I was 19 years old had never
saw cocaine had never read a book had
never hit a joint and never drunk a beer
you know I was wondering like like Mike
was dedicated sounds like old sober you
know I'm running five miles every other
day doing wind sprints and I'm like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be great you know
what I'm saying and and I was taught to
stay away from that
so when I went into that Lane when I
found myself selling drugs I don't know
what I was doing nothing you know I'm
just listening to other people telling
me what I should be doing and how it
should be doing it yeah well how do you
feel having that perspective now you
know I mean just how do you feel about
you know being the spark of the crack
epidemic in America not in any way other
than you know being who you are now you
know and seeing just the wreckage that
it causes in the individuals well well I
I have no regrets
yeah you know no regrets only lessons
yeah you know I learned some valuable
lessons from it lessons that I wouldn't
repeat but lessons that I hope other
people can look at and make the right
decision from you know so often we don't
have anybody that we can go to you know
when when I started selling drugs I
didn't know nobody that ever so cocaine
now I knew about the Nicky Barnes and
and and the guys are so hey Ron and I
wasn't gonna say hi Ron cuz I understood
what heroin was but when it came to
cocaine I didn't understand cocaine was
associate drugs yeah listen trust me we
didn't do cocaine use square exactly and
that's how I won the [ __ ] with you a
hang with you we didn't do Co you [ __ ]
you around my you do coke a mom on you
go do this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] no man I mean it's yeah
absolutely you know so so when I looked
at it that's how I looked at it ya know
this is a sociable yes
you know this is what we doing yeah it's
our generation hey let's keep it real
still this well is yeah big epidemic
cocaine you know what under grandma is
really a big epidemic right now well
then what was so interesting to me is
the real horror what was what was
happening above you oh yeah you know
that's a whole nother world the Contra
[ __ ] CIA the CIA I mean that no but
listen when you think about it right in
this perspective right okay i'ma try to
people for a black man right that's some
big [ __ ] man when you think about some
guy you know you think he's a living
Camarena right came from the ghetto yeah
I need to know me it was it was
fascinating
he had the president talking about the
president know his name politicians in
the community noses in the year like
George senior is saying I mean I mean
and that could be a real ego trip too
though it can I mean that's more
addictive than head than the money and
everything and everything just to have
that type of power in and have the did
you have other dealer from all over the
country coming trying to meet yeah meet
you will Rick it so to me it appears to
be so cosmic your life you know this
because of who you are now like Mike you
had to live this super EXTREME life and
have these experiences so that you could
come out of it and now spread good and
change the way people see the world oh
absolutely absolutely absolutely because
how many thousands of guys could have
been the guy that got connected to
Danilo no no no listen no he's right I
had to be a special person no there was
only
was only gotta be special yeah it wasn't
have you know he wouldn't have been
nobody exactly dedication that dead that
it takes you know like who's going to a
thousand squats great day right it's you
know what kind of mind says to do that
and the same thing with me it takes that
time type of mindset like who's gonna
stand out on this block who's gonna take
all this money and don't go buy a car
but put it back into the drugs to make
the connection get hooked on the money
yeah that was always my goal is to hook
the connection to where he's not gonna
want to sell anybody else drugs cuz he
knows that he can come to me and get all
his money his money gonna be on time
he's gonna be safe nothing's gonna
happen to him why he's on my watching
and that's kind of the way I practice my
trade so and that's so hard in the drug
business because everybody so grimy
yeah yeah right now it's a creep now
it's like robbed the plug is all about
creepy [ __ ] robbed the plug and
creepy and then it really bad stuff and
then if you don't like it shooting yeah
so it's it's definitely a different time
a different breed of people that that's
getting involved right now it's a trip I
mean when you found out about all the
[ __ ] going on the iran-contra deal I
didn't believe it you didn't believe
that [ __ ] now what the hell
rick ross and involved with the CIA stop
it who said that get rid of that guy I
mean I was baffled you know like not me
little Rick from South Central a we had
holes in his shoes when he was going to
school and all the kids used to laugh at
me because I had a pair of red shoes and
my mom made me wear the shoes the school
in wake up my boy you're gonna wear them
shoes I know what you're talking about
what's the most money you seen long it's
right there PO one time I had like 3.2
million cash sitting on it on the floor
you know I'm sure you know how it
you know I'm warning that it take coal
people to carry that my thought you
gotta get a copy how much of you see how
it's the most [ __ ] and they got muscle
listen right oh man I can't even tell
you this this one day when we get my
listen when we went to the bank
respected me and my wife at the time
robbery giving that right and we was
going to the bank to see where my money
was at this [ __ ] was [ __ ] with some
money some [ __ ] was going on wrong with
the money that we went to the bank right
and I didn't know where none of the
accounts that nothing I know nothing
about money I was almost like years I
didn't know nothing about money and
anything I was a dumb [ __ ] it's
not a fight I made a lot of money so um
when we got there and we really didn't
have the rights because it was under her
name up that they were stayed in like if
somebody says listen that counts her
right here we got him right here that
secret account and they've got money
must have been around nine million bucks
gosh we put a big that we kind of carry
with too much we have to leave from and
we took around a million bucks with us
and they put them in different accounts
money they're my Ghazi you carry my
money for me though I was like I ain't
carrying that [ __ ]
you carry it get that bag you get that
in here get done in no no listen this
back-breaking work though get enough fly
money I mean you know you get bored
would count it you know man they missed
the camel there's no way you could do
that like this there's no way you could
do that to the fatigue no way no no way
you get so tired cramp you start talking
you lose count
you're the [ __ ] up yeah I had three
girls with money machines to count my
money you have to do the machines cuz it
got so bad man well I mean I remember I
was counting the money by hand
my goodness and finally the guy told me
about a money counter what they got
money counters sometimes it's just so
much money you know so much [ __ ]
money like we don't even count just pack
it up don't count it
who cares backs it up who cares if you a
couple of thousand short yeah but you
can't hide it it gets to be so much
money you put in a [ __ ] car you got
to make sure now that you've got a hole
in the car that you get allowed to put
the money into the open the door the
money will crush you you know these guys
they young kids they kid teenagers and
but this when the dirty part comes at a
game when your friends start killing one
another you know guys we grew up with
all the time then he said you killed who
yo somebody died in your man then you
find out your French children we're all
friends I grew up with the school
together we stuck one in his spot we
went hit his spot and they said oh I
grew up with my four foot before I shot
out with him before and he ain't gonna
put me in on this and that's how their
minds yeah yeah well you know Java see
you owe me man I shot saved your life
before you go put me in on this crazy
[ __ ] man you owe me man I'm gonna
started doing all this [ __ ] you know
that's because that did this up because
I'm only gonna start as her she owed me
for this it's crazy you crazy
mentalities yeah you old him for life
you can never pay that debt I tried to
stay away from them kind of guys though
Mike Brown the Brooklyn F all the other
gangs a tough guy yeah they're not
satisfied till they're dead
I try to dodge him like a bad habit kill
him on ice go with a joke no no I had a
bad thing to say about him like he stole
my money did bad stuff to me he set me
up he always he's always the gentleman
yeah and I heard that you you were very
philanthropic
during your time what is that give money
away
I share I mean you know some people
called it a ping you know but when I
called it a benefit activist helping the
community yeah
you know people would come up and say oh
you know sorry so my son is in jail and
you know and the money and here my rent
is due
my car got repo'd I mean you know this
is part of being who he's supposed to be
you know we yeah I believe that we're
here on the planet to help other people
yeah there's no doubt you know I don't
think that we're here to in worship we
had a worship we were born the worship
yeah yeah afford it before there was
anything the idiots the first man
worship something the first idiot he
couldn't read right it had loaned he can
walk he worshiped something yeah what
and when you can help somebody man just
the joy that you feel when you were able
to to give somebody a hand up you know
yeah and if you ever need a hand up the
the the the feeling that you get you
know it's a total different feeling when
you got like man I need a hand looks
like it's kind of like it makes you feel
degraded like you're not you're not
vibrating and that's why so many young
black males or committing crimes because
they don't want that feeling you know
they don't want a handout feeling they
want to stand on their own feet and
right now the way that the system is set
up and the way that we've been taught
and and program is not conducive to that
you know it's it's kind of the opposite
direction yeah so what we do at homeless
people we got to help them we do that
well first first night you know my you
know you can't help nobody until you got
yourself straight you know and say I'm
straight how do we help solace people
I'm curious about
well me myself 7z
if if I was rich you know like when I
become a being in oh well I would just
build a big apartment complex you know
give all of them a place to stay we
definitely would have to set rules and
regulations you know most most of the
homeless people got mental problems so
we would have to have psychiatrists we'd
have to have doctors we probably have to
have security guards as well because
some of them have to be handled you know
some of them are just not in their right
minds if someone were sick people and
and they should be treated as such not
as they should be a mental hospital on
the property absolutely absolutely it
should be a mental hospital uh we
definitely should have mental hospitals
that that treat people with mental
illness a special way you know with with
with if my mom had a mental problem I
would want to treat it a certain way
well if I was running it I would treat
everybody with a mental illness the way
I would treat my mom you know right now
I got a friend who's taking care of his
mom she got old-timers she'll run off or
whatever and he treats her a certain way
you know he treats her like that's his
mom and and I believe that everybody
should be treated with that time how do
we how do we um police them being abused
and being raped and having babies from
these widows that are supposed to be
taking care of them like the aides I
mean I mean it's not easy it's not gonna
be an easy task
but but it's something that that has to
be done you know we have to do something
about our homeless problem otherwise
it's gonna overtake everybody you know
right now we got people living under
bridges everywhere in LA you know
everywhere you look and and not just LA
you know I get to travel the country and
speak and I see the same type of
situation all over the country and we
just have to do something about it and I
believe that and and even here in
California you know the taxpayers
they're possibile where everybody agreed
to take more out of their taxes to to do
something about the homeless but now our
politicians is not know they need to be
programmed not given Nikki they don't
know what to do with money you can't
give them money to give them programs
that can educate them like a program
them to take care of themselves
or to go to some particular kind of
venue that can take care of absolutely I
totally agree I totally agree
we need psychiatrists is that have their
best interests at heart matter of fact I
just went and spoke at a home the other
day for uh for some some women who have
mental problems you know they supposed
to be NGO but they were weren't
competent to stand trial so what they're
doing now is they're putting me in these
little houses and they have about twenty
girls living here and I went and spoke
to him and and what I told them is that
if you don't fight you're your sickness
and you allow your sickness to take over
then you have been a victim but if you
fight your sickness to come out of it to
be a better person to stop yourself from
doing whatever crime you did to get
yourself in this position and then you
become a winner as soon as you start to
do that yeah absolutely but when I
become a billionaire I'm gonna do
something about it you know I'm not
gonna be one of these billionaires who
they get the money and they put it in a
bank and they get the ride around and
tell everybody oh look how rich I am
look what kind of car I got you know
look how many girlfriends I got Mike
wants to build something for homeless
people
no mike is right we should build
something absolutely we should build
something to set a standard that that
the rest of the world will marvel at and
say wow absolutely they they did that
for they're sick and they're dead al
yeah you know that's the American Way
you know that's the way that I was
always taught America should be you know
there's always been like that because we
know that it
America's about competition and about
image competitiveness competitiveness an
image yeah and we got to change that you
know we have to come in here and and set
a new tone you know we can't we can't
let this environment dictate to us who
we are and who we're going to become you
know right now with all of the hate
crimes and people walking in churches
shooting people and and all that is a
reflection of what this country has
become yeah you know and and if we don't
correct it it's only gonna get worse I
mean we're saying people go in and shoot
innocent kids I mean unheard of you know
10 or 15 years ago you know you never
would have thought that nobody was going
to a school now we know school kids
shoot each other you know gangs and
stuff like that but I'm saying like a
guy just goes into the school and just
randomly start shooting innocent people
that they never saw before never had
that's only in America you know other
parts of the world that's going after
years you know I mean because most parts
of the world always be more aggressive
than the American public had the guys
like The Jackal yet that the bottom line
half gang those guys from the sixties
all those terrorists European gangs and
stuff they really did a number of the
sixties and seventies and stuff and
early eighties they they're the one that
created Yasser Arafat and all those guys
and stuff but but those guys are
fighting over property though huh they
were fighting over property they
fighting over land no they were fighting
over cause but it but it but it but it
wrinkled down there all that stuff
string comes down to us well drink goes
down it'll sink goes down to the Empire
State building's the two trades tended
to getting crushed with the airplane it
all trickles down to that all the
shingles down yeah you know I mean but
these Nona takes going at the church is
going in churches and schools and just
like shooting everybody they never seen
before never had an argument with them I
mean
yeah that's strange there's just so many
mentally ill people you know we don't do
anything but they feed they they feed
their mental illness the wrong stuff you
sir when you start feeding the mental
illness guns and violence and pills in
peels I don't think they mentally I
think this is something they want to do
I think this is a belief system and this
is what they believe in and I think
they're doing it for a court whatever
cause there may be a racial cause a
spiritual call the religious core what
if that's their called I don't believe
they mentally ill you right now some of
them do have that that religious issue
and then I don't know I mean you know
how complicated life is to deal with
that's why people kill them so I can't
do this you throw uh no they don't say
hold on for them you get me count to ten
take these some deep breath and let me
go on again I just won it over what I
can't take the [ __ ] pay crazy and
there's only in an illusion the
paintings are an illusion when I was so
be a little bit of a shift but when I
was a freshman in high school I had a
teacher who grew up in LA and he said
that these trucks or containers or
trains used to show up open full of
drugs and guns I heard those stories and
I was like no [ __ ] way and then
watching your movie last night I was
like they were doing that that was
happening well my guys were bringing in
droves in on military planes right right
that was an operation the operation I
mean yeah you know but this seemed to me
like they were open for anyone to come
in or someone to come in and take the
guns and the drugs people from the
community I don't know I heard those
stories that they left trains over there
for four weeks and stuff with full of
guns and and I never saw it and never
participated in in in the gun by but
I've heard those stories hmm like I said
my guys were they had the military back
and so yeah they they flew their drugs
well then it's really interesting to me
to when they would show the drug busts
on TV like there was one big drug bust
in the movie they talked about and they
do a big press conference and they talk
about these drugs he show the drugs they
show all the drugs and they talk about
how great they did like making this bust
and it's like why is there this show
when they're involved in the circulation
of them and no one I don't think anyone
would really care whether the bust was
made or not if they didn't know what the
drugs were does that make sense a little
bit a little bit well it's it's a lot to
that that you just said first of all
they want to make the bus because the
bus is tied today paycheck the more
drugs they find the more people they
arrest the bigger the paycheck the
bigger the budget now we can write in
and say okay we found ten thousand kilos
of cocaine well the other precinct only
found a thousand kilos of cocaine so our
budget should be bigger than theirs
because we're fighting a bigger problem
yeah so so their bottom line depends on
how big the bus is and and when they get
it so and they they just automatically
want to increase these numbers yeah you
don't want everybody to see how awesome
they are so you think that you were like
a really big kingpin right right so tell
me you got a lot of [ __ ] not like Floyd
yeah well you know anytime you you
running around Los Angeles and you know
you can put your hands on a couple
million dollars at any given time women
like you you know they you know most
women are looking for security they're
looking for some guy that's what it is
oh absolutely absolutely that's the
first time you know
you know I used to think like when I
when I was young I just think like oh he
must be good-looking cuz he got a fine
woman but later on I found out it don't
matter how good the guy looked what can
he do for you know what kind of car he
had I don't say I don't believe that
because I've known about putting this
been friendly with someone with a lot of
resources and they need to believe that
they're loved you know they don't
believe they're not love they don't
believe they're worthy of anything yeah
yeah hmm
that's strange I don't know hey listen I
think that's real strange you know some
some women can't [ __ ] they can't they
can't enjoy it it hurts
some people are really some people
really [ __ ] up I never had that
problem I mean you know know that I mean
you just can't have our own kids and
I've got smoothly just something's wrong
with them that they can't have it you
can't take it
yeah this doesn't work well with nobody
that will care how big your just with
nobody then work out well no no I never
seen that I mean I'm like what you're
proud that when you had to bring it to
me
and we're gonna test it out I think um
when people get to a certain stage of
life I believe that material things they
just they don't mean anything they want
they want something they want to figure
out who they are what's my purpose here
in life what's going on that's after you
that's after you straight though that's
after you got everything and then you
can start thinking like that what when
you when you don't have anything and
you're sleeping under bridge then it's
like how do I get from under this bridge
and and and most and let me say most
black women that I known we're looking
for security you know how can I get out
of my mama's house how can I become
secure in my business and and men too
you know because one one of the things
that breakup most families black
families is
money problems you know how are we gonna
pay the rent
you didn't pay the light bill this month
it was your turn the coordinators late
so you see that's listener I'm not um I
can't send myself a low income parents
this is my it's not a problem but this
is weird I think my kids they date white
guys my daughter she dates a white guy
got vicinity it's white girl so I say to
myself till I say this to me I let I
lived the [ __ ] up example for them so
you know that's when you told her that's
what I think that was just so my mommy
did that I must have let a [ __ ] up
example as a black man to my daughter
you know so that's why I think to myself
sometimes right I don't think you do
with that could be because it's the
because of her lifestyle she lived she's
more I don't know I see probably around
oh yeah that's when I come to my mind
sometimes um I didn't leave a good
example I wasn't good to a mother
cheated allowed me and I mother fought a
lot of what [ __ ] never money it's
all of me
but some other woman that's all it was
so probably this [ __ ] gonna cheat on
me all the time well you know I fight
with me but she had everything she had
everything once once you have once you
have all your necessities then you have
to look for things that you don't have
and things that are not right and and
say for instance somebody's hungry we're
not going to be worried about you
cheatin see you're gonna be what about
getting something to eat that's our
first first priority so once all your
necessities are taken care of then you
start to worry about the things that are
least important so I believe that when
people are in a certain position their
priorities change you know like most of
the I spent substantial right now I'm
still standing to get oh you know most
of the guys over they don't have jobs
they come over and ask me for a job they
work for a hundred hours a week you know
because they don't have any money so
when you don't have any money you're
probably already be comes to get you
some money because you know without
money in this country you can't eat you
can't sleep you can't buy gas you can't
use the bathroom you know you're going
to gas station now and you want to use a
bathroom
by nothing and we don't have people to
use the bathroom here any customers so
so it economics is so so important
in the black community right now and I
have to speak you know yeah to that
without the economics the crime rate is
not gonna go down
gangs are gonna keep going we have to do
something to to to knock knock it down
you know where they have the basic
necessities to to survive do you have
any ideas of where to start
oh yeah you start with yourself you know
first you get yourself together and then
once you what I know in front of drug
business and how I got so wealthy in the
drug business is once I had figured it
out for myself I figured out how I could
take $225 and I could turn it into a
million bucks I figured that out so once
I figured it out I just had to start
teaching my friends you know I went from
one after another one and teach them
okay that's how you do it
don't get high if you get high you ain't
gonna get no money you got to make a
choice that you want to be a addict
do you want to be a millionaire you know
mostly Tanya so you all want to be a
millionaire but I'm still gonna get I
[Laughter]
and and you know it's it's cut more
common in I've seen them getting on and
still get their money but it's it's a
harder process is rare really messy
because you know you want to spend all
your time and I like you hold on I'm
gonna take care of that when I finish
this one here with my friends and stuff
like we see each other on the weekends
we be partying I answer but from Monday
to Friday
that's killing they're setting up their
deals this man is a hell of a life and
sometimes you know you see the crew and
sometimes excluded you used to seeing
they disappear some of them are missing
you know Mike I know you took care a lot
of your guys though or let's go save
them yeah all the time so they only had
to do one mystery so all the time
yeah so some good medicine but some guys
that youth can't stop they not the money
they won't go back to the streets no
it's not the money not he didn't wanted
this you wanna listen it's that glory to
to have people fraid of you fearing you
that's the drug they love that could get
anybody else to buy we do see their to
do like what you did give everything
that you want and then still want to be
in the streets but that's insane
stay away from the street streets under
feet that's that mental hospital it
either been a mental hospital can't win
streets and the streets don't forgive
know a little bit yeah once you get out
there it's rough but I believe in that
that's my goal right now is to become
successful first for myself and my
family and and then so that I can show
other people how to do it you know how
to how to get out of poverty what are
you going about how did you make income
well he just an income right now yes
marijuana yeah I just started my bait
peon company I sell cars babe I thought
that was a plan I sell cars what kind of
cars yourself I can get anything you
want any car you want you can holla at
me I'll get it for you I'm gonna get you
a deal - I got my t-shirt line that I'm
doing I got two books out now I got my
first book my autobiography and then I
got a my new book that just came out -
21 keys of success and that book came
about it's about my first six months out
of prison well you know how I got out of
prison and I was homeless for a while
when I first got out I was homeless
believe it or not nobody nobody would
help me out you know I had all the
intentions
and everything but uh when you're not
doing good nobody's gonna respect you
know I got a prison with 200 bucks and I
had to take that and go to work with it
and now I got a nice crew about 20
people that I'm working with maybe 30
and uh we we don't we don't build this
thing into a billion dollar industry
starting you know Americans are taught
that poverty them contagious Americans
we're taught to believe that impoverish
contagious we stay away from their
poverty orientated this roofless yeah
it's really cold
yeah property is ruthless yeah you ain't
gotta do nothing I mean it's horrible
you know with the homeless situation in
LA because so many people just want to
isolate them and send them away and not
help on the hey Melissa I'm Evan the gap
between the rich and the poor Ian so big
something bad if you ready to happen
now our tutors getting great now and now
our children gotta worry we don't make
this better and make you know take care
of this problem our children our
children our kids like me in trouble
trouble the world gonna be in trouble
those that the world is gonna be our kid
those are the users right you right you
right
the world is definitely in trouble if we
don't so it's our goal I mean that's the
gap that should be at that should be our
mission as people right now to figure
out how to solve the problems that we
have been and and that's that's what I
want to do I mean I would love to be
like you know when it all said and done
they'd be like man Rick came up with the
solution man I love he's the plug the
new plug a new plug again you know so
that's awesome man I got to ask you
about what's his name
William Roberts says name the fake Rick
Ross yeah what about that man why is he
a bad guy tell me man seems like a sweet
guy was wrong
well whose response to you to really
turn me off I'm not offending anymore
I think he called me a rat Jim down say
what he said I'm a rat I'm down on my
luck and well he didn't he shouldn't
have said that
yeah yeah not news my name I mean like
I'm using your quarry I took your car
Mike and I drove it to the thing and
everybody recognized me and I got a deal
but I'm gonna keep the car and I'm gonna
get you know boy you know I said some
black people you have to know how to
learn how to love each other then we
learned how to love each other
collectively you mean yeah group of
people and I don't love each other
yeah but you know I don't really have
much bad to say about noon on a tow job
and I never did
yeah very honorable I don't dislike the
guy yeah you know I think he's the clown
dough yeah you know yeah well he's
revealed himself to be that because he
could have been really cool about it and
been really respectful and I mean he
could have been so much you know I felt
that that me and him together could have
did some powerful thing sure he's still
quite up it still can listen it was
interesting sometimes we gotta take I
felt out of the equation our feelings
out of the equation you know I mean
forget what anybody think this is a good
thing we can't move together possible we
can't work there for you or people with
fit
no but we'll be seeing that the purpose
I don't think you work let me know free
Wilma and I gave all four isn't it I
don't know I mean if he came today and
say you wanted to I'd be like oh where
is it
what's the situation show people some
people you told me Todd I was one of
those guys come on you find out [ __ ]
you feel like killing it that I was
[ __ ] - yeah so where's that
situation came out of it yeah I don't
know I mean his numbers
down on the charts I don't know buddy
still using work I think he does
universal one in the username they won't
let him change it yeah they'll put money
on it yeah but uh I don't know you know
uh
right now man I'd be so tied up in
myself and what they're doing that that
is hard for me that I course to like
recognized you know like like somebody
was telling me about some boots was in
my house one day somebody had on I was
like man I don't be looking at no come
on
I'm bigger than that you know so just
don't pay attention to him you know yeah
I know they don't have to here's music
on the radio anymore you know they
stopped praying his music on the radio
so plant him at the after he lost a loss
I mean I he won a lawsuit he's still
playing but now I mean you know or
korvac Lee we rap music though it has it
it has a time cycle you know like oh you
hot today you might be hot two weeks or
three weeks and then all of a sudden
you're gone you know not to be heard of
again you know that they go and they
repo your house and get all the cars and
like man we just known you that that was
none of yours you was faking this wasn't
real true but what I really don't like
about it is the image that it portrays
to our kids you know our kids start to
believe that these guys made all of this
money selling drugs and that there was
killers and and then our kids go out and
practice the things that these guys
wrapped about which was totally fake
and that's one of my biggest gripes with
the whole the whole industry and that he
took a real name that's going down in
history you know that's in law books and
used that name to portray a lie and I
really have an issue with that you know
I have an issue that the kids don't know
his real name when I go to schools and
speak sometime the kids ask me why did I
change my name to Rick Ross and I said
well you gonna have to talk to my mama
that's not my birth certificate that's
not a
Monica you know I'm I'm the real deal
I really didn't the real robber oh I
went to prison I have federal agents you
know uh surrounding my place door down
yeah keep the door down this ain't a rap
video you know that my documentary is is
is is real life experiences so our kids
don't really understand how to decipher
real from fake because everybody is
allowing them to do but it's been times
I went to schools to speak to the kids
and I wasn't allowed in they didn't
allow me to speak but then I hang around
at the football game in the basketball
game and they plan these rap records
from this guy who's talking about he's a
drug dealer
interesting why weren't they why didn't
they let you in they are afraid of a
real drug dealer
hmm they think you're gonna be telling
the kids to like go sell drugs kids
right but now if you a fake drug dealer
who brags about selling drugs yeah
that's cool man you okay cuz you didn't
really do it it's really interesting the
time to change that you can are those
guys um Evan and I cannot community a
lot of guys in you know it's a lot of
those guys and I hear no more a lot of
guys in the first um like the first wave
of rappers and stuff when they're
playing tough guys other guys that was
really tough let's say oh yeah you are
tough guy oh you really are a bad
[ __ ] you killing [ __ ] like
that you got [ __ ] all like that and
dope and money and Jerry and their dad
was there a target cuz they got those
Eagle guys like oh yeah your badass
[ __ ] you got Jerry where that
hmm and that's what those guys on the
street they don't have nothing
yeah but those that that wave of people
are not around anymore yeah you know I
mean they put big laws and now they get
the hip hop police so most of the
rappers and stuff has protection they
better you know got vicious vicious and
then they go steal the gold and they
found out it was fake
they went fake jury like man I did all
this I took a penance in church and then
they want to kill him yeah that's the
world is out here all the music is used
to control the youth it's been that way
forever yeah but we got to start doing
some music that is uplifting educational
and that will send us forward because if
we continue down they get one of those
songs out of a thousand yeah what a
record I was not gonna promote him
record was not gonna promote them
they're not you know they don't care
they they want the bottom line for their
for their investors but it's gonna be up
to people like us to to to spread the
word about how this system I mean even
like with my movie mama we should have
been out yeah when we should have been
out but when I'm talking to these guys
from Hollywood they try to convince me
how much people are not gonna watch my
movie you know and I'm like you can't
convince me that because I live in the
streets I live with the people because
they want you to say hey take this
hundred thousand obviously your life
[ __ ] story alright and we want to buy
your rights and the hundred thousand
dollars and that's cool and we're gonna
sell your rights 400 million dollar
exactly yeah and you be happy you'll be
happy [ __ ] so I just feel that they
have to deal with me different because
my morals is no longer tied to money
because what I found out if I tie it
myself to money I can sell cocaine to my
family members or to anybody
oh yeah they'll give you your money why
soon she's telling these iPods and stuff
they'll give you money put it out there
they'll give you money give you money
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna stay on the
head I've been on the head I told them
they better pay my money if they want me
to quit those people don't like bad
reputation the whole life is on the
river fake reputation
no damage reputation yeah but uh that's
pretty much the way I've been handling
it and just going around trying to show
people how they can have the same type
of success that that I'm having right
now beautiful guy told me it was like
man mic mic gonna interview you man I
said man Mike Tyson they all just sound
I was your name came up earlier that's
good that's good well you know I've been
on here working hard man I haven't taken
a day off in ten years you know every
single day I wake up with the same
mindset that I have to make the world a
better place you know and if I don't who
else to do it yeah I love that
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that wait
think about this world what do you think
you go after we've finished in this
world I think we've done no what do you
think it's over the blackout is that
that's it energy that you know atoms
never die yes all that energy so much of
physical the energy gonna continue to
live you know that energy that that that
we have today it never dies you know how
do you know never dying what scientists
say that atoms live forever you can't
you can't kill atoms so so we all have
atoms in us and we made atoms so we'll
continue to live but do I believe it
there's a heaven
you know then I'm going no I don't
believe I don't believe so do you
believe this was just a black beans no
more do you believe that your Energy's
gonna go when you can look here so damn
to yourself no no I don't believe that
cool I don't I don't like stuff I
believe that my legacy is gonna dictate
how things should be going for years you
know that's what I want I want my legacy
to live on like Rick showed us this this
is how you should do you know one of my
one of my coaches you know my tennis
coach he used to tell me that you live
until the last person speak your name
and once that's over it in that's it
you're done who knows who the last
person is maybe it's your great great
great great grand kid no maybe it's some
person who picks up your book and read
it and was like wow I got a lot out of
that from old that old guy you know who
live back in 1980 and imagine all this
we experience right now yes an illusion
of existence well it is illusion but
it's in my mind you know I believe that
that that we create our own dreams and
all you guys are just in my dream one
day you got to read the article they did
on me a Nelly magazine they was writing
my obituary they thought I'd die Wow yes
this guy wrote he wrote he was like I'm
here I wrote out to Lompoc
penitentiary were gun tires me razor
wire and I'm going to see Freeway Ricky
Ross and this is the last time I'll be
writing about him he's gone he's throw
the world is tired of his dreaming they
don't want him to dream no more and then
when he came out there I was telling
them I heard maxine waters talk about
you a lot use your name of Maxine's he
loves me I love accents my lady not like
that if her husband here but that's you
know I football player yeah I know yes
yes to beat up on Ricky oh no no Sydney
Sydney Sydney waters yeah but in that
article III pretty much was laying out
to to this guy what I'm doing right now
that that I was going to be in this
position you know and and
he spoke it into existence that's how we
do it oh yeah it's like selling drugs
right like look I spoke and to exist in
being a drug dealer cuz I go watch this
movie Mike I know you think super fly
super fly guy right but listen because
isn't if he lived in a community like
mine that's what was based on you know
the solstar community filter that
community yeah yeah and they sold it to
me yeah so now look I go see this movie
not still love were at the ass right but
I just saw a black man stay down like
ten white cops he break them down like
oh you you saw the movie my guess you
could do my dirty laundry if you want to
that hang on her anything I'll help you
listen man when I sort of Mackin what
was the other one Willie dynamite that
really turned me out
we are Willie dynamite yard I was good I
saw all those but I just super fly was
mine I had when I got my first DDR on
two movies Superfly Scarface then was my
first two movies man we watched him over
and over every day I'm sitting in the
crack house selling crack out the door
watching Superfly like oh get on there
girl and and that's what that's what I
became I became super like go there the
guys in our neighborhood you know crazy
man and it's crazy how when I was in
prison I started to think about that
right cuz look at this here then I went
back into my life and then like I
stashed my girl and you're gonna run for
me when I go to jail I ain't never been
in a police car
but I'm accident you're gonna run for me
when I when I go to jail I'm gonna tell
you what she said leave that out so when
I'm in jail now and I'm looking back at
my life and I'm starting it I'm starting
you know become a conscious you know
Mike
damn quick you know you thought your way
in jail
I said not can't work like that
don't you think your way out of jail din
if you think you thought your way in
think your way out but that's how I got
out of prison because I started to think
my way out like I thought my way in just
like right now I'm gonna think of a way
to solve the problems that we have in in
our community with the homeless with the
like a jobs with gang activity with all
of the things that are healed in our
community and some of them that I know I
helped fuel from selling drugs now it's
my goal to to stop those things and
that's my mission right now that's what
that's when I'm on I ain't I ain't on
the money but I know I got to get the
money say I know I got to get the money
I got to change the perception we have
of ourselves one another but we need
somebody to show us that we should
change because see how can you change
the lesson you know that you should
change well you should know you
shouldn't you shouldn't talk to people
in certain ways you should know like how
do you know that if nobody ever teaches
you if nobody never shows a common
[ __ ] know it ain't common I want to
come in common no my kin ain't close
when I get bullied I was looking I got
bullied and throw your stupid [ __ ]
what you doing in [ __ ] I would say why
I would like today I wish this my friend
and talk to me like that once he did I
know he could do it they kick me rape me
slice my throat he'd do anything to me
you know I mean that's the first thing I
wouldn't know I went with nobody wanting
to feel the way I felt wait because he
talked to me that way
right I agree but what I'm saying is
that he didn't know that he shouldn't
talk to you like that he didn't know
that he was you think he talked to the
mother like that he probably didn't but
he may have spoke but Mike what I'm
saying this and what I'm saying this is
what I'm trying to say I don't even know
if I got it right I could I could be
totally off off you go you know I'm
saying but i'ma try to I'm gonna try to
explain it how can you
you know if nobody ever taught you when
all the people that taught you taught
you that this the way you should be
acting you can talk to act like this
this is not you but once you are taught
to act like that you believe it this is
the way you should be yeah well my
mother taught me yes ma'am no man yes
sir no matter I thought I was that my
ass kicked but you were different though
I'm saying I'm saying that the normal
teaching right now right now to teaching
on the street be your gangster
be tough beat the plug steal Rob lie
fake do whatever you got to do to make
it yeah and even if you ain't made it
fake it you know so so this becomes your
reality this becomes our reality of not
having but fake like you have you know
spend your last dollar to look good even
though [ __ ] is [ __ ] up you know you
only took a shower but you got on new
clothes yeah you know and this is the
the the perception that this world has
has been teaching people man so I don't
I don't and yet the person who did that
to you he holds some responsibility but
I look at it like this II they try to
they try to front me down right and make
me feel bad about myself and they said
we'll look how many people that you
messed up when you saw drugs I said yeah
I'm a bad guy but then what about the
guy who taught me how to sell drugs does
he hold some responsibility for teaching
me what I learned from him and then we
got to go back to the guy that told him
I mean you know you could just keep coin
and the people who decided to buy the
drugs drugs you don't have no end
responsibility to because if they didn't
buy it the guy who taught me you
probably wouldn't even been selling it
because all the people who taught them
that they needed to buy these drugs to
feel a certain way that made them
there we go there we go so you just keep
going I'm gonna thank you go home that's
why I think your point about it starts
with yourself it's so powerful man
because if you can teach everybody to
take care of yourself first and get
right with that then you can start to
make change in the world and people
around amen I agree meant to be in the
society they've been inside since the
beginning well they'll always be here
humans are not the only animal to get
high yeah no you know Jaguars will eat
the vine that create that holds the DMT
yeah and they'll be super other than
Zeitz our oranges yeah yeah get a bus I
mean you know a lot of people don't want
to deal with what's going on around them
so they just want to mellow out man how
much look I'm just gonna mellow out man
on my hit of joint I'm gonna hit a joint
okay [ __ ] with nobody bother nobody
I just wanna be here and seal out that's
right man I mean you know it's all about
how you use them you know how you use
them and then if we if we if we want to
to fight the war on drugs I believe it
starts with with education yeah you know
we already know there's been reports to
show that there's money is better spent
on prevention and intervention
you know incarceration and all that
that's you don't work you don't stop the
like I know guys in NGO making plans
with the communes you know you're like
oh man we finished in shitloads over
here it doesn't even do anything nothing
so putting them in jail it's they're
still doing business bigger yeah
sometimes bigger you make them bigger
when you do time in prison that will get
you by your mind being stimulated
sometimes but when your mind stimuli you
know shit's going out we're making money
we're doing it we're doing this [ __ ] on
for McCollum's go be a [ __ ] see no no I
was stimulated and pitted was like I was
like at a camp of my you know it's a
ball and it was just stimulating
we just kept yourself busy yeah yeah you
got to you got to our stay busy to die
learn how to read there yeah a little
laser right over 300 books isn't
wonderful learn how to be nothing oh god
that's another words I went to China
right I mean I'm gonna meet you I read
this life story mouthing Chung I was in
[ __ ] China another life the history
of the [ __ ] country man I go there
talk about everything I learned from the
book how you know so much about China
because I was in prison I read the book
and China feel like in that article that
I was telling you about the guy talked
about when I tell him that I might be
more freer when I was in prison than I'd
ever been before my life because now I
had learned how to visualize how to
fantasize how to open up my mind when
before my mind was trapped in South
Central Los Angeles which was
penitentiary Brown like I'm going to the
penitentiary you know I wasn't in
penitentiary I got all the news for
people oh call people in such-and-such
got killed it isn't it and I will call
[ __ ] for the field what happens I
didn't get killed me he got killed I
didn't know you got killed you know I
would get all the news first it don't
think what happened to this but what
happened after I heard this now you
finally [ __ ] out make your imprison and
the word in the world just comes yeah
yeah it circulates around that prisoner
but it's just you know I mean I don't
know life is it's crazy you know and and
I'm just gonna keep being crazy in it
and keep letting my mind run free you
know I don't want my mind to be
incarcerated
you know strike the other day I went to
jail the other day like a week ago
tell me about that how did that work oh
man man my son is hitting my side that
you met we sit in the car and was just
sitting there and the cops pulled in the
driveway and they got they lights out so
you know you automatically know
something is up cops at nighttime
they're cops riding with their lights
out look out so they walk up to the car
and ask me for my ID I handed my ID and
everything and I'm like
it's gonna be nice and quick and then
they said you're on parole and I said
nope and then the other cop had walked
over to my son nasan was he on parole
and then my son said yeah he said oh
this one over here is on parole and one
next to me said oh you lied to me and I
said no I didn't lie to you I told you I
wasn't on parole and I'm not get out of
the car so they snatched us out the car
and then he asked me to sit on the
ground I said no not sitting on the
ground oh you're gonna sit on the ground
no I'm not gonna sit on the ground you
might throw me on the ground but I'm not
gonna sit on the ground it's a
difference so he started trying to
handcuff me you ain't finna handcuff me
handcuffed me for what you know like I
need this [ __ ] and uh next thing I know
it's parting to grab me and they both
had me by the arms and took me to the
ground and put his knee in my back
roughed me up and they took me to jail
for obstruction of an investigation so
they gave me a ticket
let me out in about six hours you know
I'm like come on man Twitter and what a
nut sac said give me a second I want a
sack put me in a Cell I want to take a
nap
you know put me in jail it don't scare
me going to jail like I did 20 years I
can do six hours on the handstand matter
of fact I'm gonna do two push-ups the
whole six hours that I'm here so but
what it did show me is the state of this
society the way they still look at a
black man in this country that we can be
made to sit on the ground roll over and
I ain't rolling over you know I ain't
laying down I ain't sitting down a
listen I want to sit down if somebody
asks me who I want to sit down for I
might sit down but I'm not doing none of
that you know I'm gonna stand up I'm
gonna be a man now for what I believe in
and if it means going to jail for what I
believe in or whatever the consequences
may be for what I believe in then that's
what it is so that's why I didn't sit on
the ground that's why I went to jail and
if they came and they did it today
they would take me to jail again and
every time they asked me to sit on the
ground so all the cops out there
watching if you ask me to sit on the
ground you had to take me to jail so
[ __ ] up man
but I love you Rick
Thank You Man thank you man I really
appreciate that on the moon love Mike
Mike it was great to have you here come
on man
yeah all the time
laughing that's [ __ ] what's that diliman
like so much time in jail yeah glad you
guys are out doing a lot of good man
we're gonna do more good man and a lot
more to come for Mike one day we gotta
go to one of them high schools and talk
to the kids man they would love to see
you you know I went to high school just
now I went to a [ __ ] high school the
other day and nothing different in years
ago and then I went to the classroom so
the principal had this big [ __ ]
screen and so he's shown the kids my
fight for the kids the kids didn't know
the [ __ ] or what they said my type of
the guy from the movie The Hangover it
had no idea I was a [ __ ] fighter
that's the movie Edison regular pencil
was saying no he was a fighter you had
no idea what the fight that that was a
fighter
in the mean time just slide so bad one
of the greatest well thank you thank you
brother
the People's Champ somebody told me that
you say to people's champ
that's right did the People's Champ is
more important than the belt
yeah somebody told me you said that yes
he said didn't you could had a belt but
you ain't got the people you ain't got
nothing and I want the people that's for
sure keep the belt keep the money I was
I was just always in the streets with
the people I was just a street person I
just happened to be the champ and I
fought they told me they say Mikey
streets for people somebody told me my
keys being south central a plan catch
football with the kids could I used to
date some girls out there and and uh
they say he would be in the middle of
street and all of a sudden like ten cars
will pull up Mike you got to go there
you can't be over your plant foot
bothers to hang out with the people
I'm going on Mike used to be I heard
this in jail this is stuff they was
taught mine in jail like like man Mike
was on such a street the other day plan
touch football in the middle of street
with the kids
like ten cars pulled up and they jumped
out hey Mike you can't be over here like
this Mike come on let's go
that's who he is yep I'm never gonna be
afraid of the people though you know
imagine me being afraid of the people
I'll be afraid of myself you know it's
awesome it's awesome way to be should we
wrap this thing Mike oh yeah I know what
time is it man no it's like midnight
everybody yeah give us them from a
million people looking at chicken find
me on my social media Freeway Ricky on
all the social media art across the
board also if I didn't bring my books
with me today sorry he's gonna play you
in the movie man childish gambino crazy
I don't know nothing about nobody
somebody hit put a picture up of me and
him on social media and cuz I didn't
know who he was I'd heard a song dog you
know this is America I've heard that
song but I didn't know the name of the
artist and and then when they put the
picture up and they told me who he was
and I know my casting director she gonna
have a fit for me saying that dope
choice man
good choice yeah but that's what I want
the script is almost done
shout-out to my script script doctor of
cush Reginald Hudlin and are there good
the brothers right yeah that's who
that's what better we don't independent
yes totally independent and and then
this is i'ma say they said I'm gonna get
ready to go this is what the movie is
supposed to capture a young man that
wants a car and a girl
leave it at that peace y'all hit me up
one love hey what about that show that
should have some television
we're free right no with another show
with that show that story for free just
change the name he read the book uh-huh
and how similar the book understand the
show is but you know what hey y'all
stole it peace
enjoy yourself I'm gonna do something
else you're more creative because I got
an open mind
thank you everybody for watching and
listening I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike
Tyson and we're out of here y'all won
all right that was cool
[Music]
[Music]